dix années ça fait dix ans les gars en
vieilli il ya dix années qui sont
passées depuis que j'ai mis en ligne la
première vidéo de la chaîne autant vous
dire qu'on a commencé moi faire des
vidéos et vous a traîné sur youtube
quand on était hyper jeunes parce qu'on
est encore jeune dix ans après bon plus
pour très longtemps apparemment vu comme
ça passe vite mais écoutez à l'occasion
de ses 10 ans et le prétexte parfait
pour faire juste une grosse vidéo blabla
dans plein de nostalgie comme on les
aime
et en vrai disant c'est ouf les gars je
passe vous rendez compte mais il ya des
gens qui m'ont connu quand il était au
collège et actuellement ils ont un
métier et un enfant et une calvitie
aujourd'hui j'ai très envie de discuter
de ces dix ans c'est un truc de fou je
savais même pas que youtube ça allait
durer 10 ans il ya tellement de trucs
nouveaux chaque année il ya tellement de
nouvelles personnes qui créent du
contenu il ya tellement de nouveaux
médias de nouvelles manières de
consommer du contenu que c'était pas dit
que ça allait durer des heures des
choses ont pris des proportions assez
folle et pas que pour moi pour beaucoup
de gens de la plata je veux dire
youtuber ça y est c'est devenu un métier
c'est plus la honte de dire que tu perds
c'est un métier où c'est incroyable non
à l'époque souvenez vous c'est devenu un
métier donc en 2010 est de regarder des
jeux vidéos de les commenter est-ce que
manger des pizzas c'est devenu un métier
maintenant dans les formulaires quand il
demande la profession tu peux marquer
youtuber et c'est ok les gens
comprennent et c'est totalement et demi
c'est fou j'ai pas les stades de ça je
sais pas combien de gens parmi ceux qui
regardent actuellement les vidéos sont
là depuis combien de temps mais j'ai la
sensation au vu de ce que je peux lire
sur le web ou de ce que vous me dites
quand on se croise dans la rue et où il
ya quand même beaucoup beaucoup
d'anciens quoi genres les plus anciens
des anciens ont découvert youtube à
l'époque avec la triplette légendaire du
diable ou x9 du monsieur le v12 et de
wardek était de youtube heures gaming
mais vous m'avez probablement connu à
l'époque grâce au défi de squeeze qui
consistait à faire des bêtises
en juin un call of duty typique d'un
adolescent de 15 ans à l'époque où je
donnerai des trucs dans la maison
familiale avec mes potes de lycée nous
casser les couilles à mon frère qui
était juste dans la chambre juste au
dessus et qu'ils m'entendent et rage et
sur les jeux du coût des fois je le
quitte d'un pays venaient dans une vidéo
avec moi et je pense que beaucoup de
gens ont rejoint la chaîne à ce moment
là parce que c'est quand j'étais encore
dans la maison de ma mère que cyprien
lancé cyprien gaming et que donc là
beaucoup de gens m'ont découvert grâce
au tremplin que ça a été vous on a
vraiment grandi ensemble
on a regardé les mêmes séries au même
moment on a découvert les mêmes choses
au même moment on apprend le moins une
relation amoureuse au même moment pas
ensemble mais on a découvert la fille en
même temps puisqu'on avait même moche
quoi vous l'avez vu récemment j'ai
changé de décor j'ai changé la photo de
profil de la chaîne la bannière et c'est
con mais c'est des trucs qui montre
qu'il ya un peu une page qui se tourne
en soi quand je fais ces changements là
ça change rien mais quand même
psychologiquement on se dit waouh ça
montre que le temps passe en fait et y
en a certains qui bat un peu d'ailleurs
on se rend compte de ça tant qu'on parle
des décors ensuite il ya eu ce décor là
quand j'ai eu mon premier appart j'étais
fier j'avais 18 ans et grâce à la
youtube relais j'avais plus loin un
appart à arcueil cachan j'étais trop
content de malade et je pense qu elle
aussi pas mal d'entre vous qui sont
arrivés à ce moment là à l'époque on
faisait pas mal de queenstown tab y
avait aussi le premier let's play sur
aliens isolation c'est l'époque aussi où
je jouais énormément de jeu d'horreur
c'était très à la mode léger d'horreur à
l'époque puis après après ça s'est un
peu perdue c'est l'époque aussi où
c'était l'essor des jeux indépendants il
y avait des nouveaux jeux indés tous les
jours et plus le jeu c'était n'importe
quoi plus les youtuber y jouer et là un
an après la youtube monnaie se fait
sentir et je me dis je veux une maison
et j'en trouve une gens trouvent une
allée grande c'est cool et elle sert à
rien puisque je passe ma vie dans cette
pièce là qu'est mon bureau dans la
maison là où je tourne toutes mes vidéos
et aussi je passe tout le reste de mon
temps puisque je passe ma vie à jouer au
jeu quand je suis pas en train de faire
des vidéos cette époque là elle était
cool aussi peut-être que mal connus à ce
moment là c'était l'époque de quoi des
jeux point you avec à gharios avec
sneijder poyaud qu'est-ce qui a eu à
cette époque là il ya le let's play sur
une tilda on à l'époque était vraiment
quel jeu
au fait le site voulait jamais fait et
puis le temps passe le temps passe et là
on en vient aux décors où je pense que
beaucoup de gens m'ont découvert à ce
moment là le fameux studio qui pour la
première fois n'était pas là où
j'habitais mais était ailleurs et la
raison ça je l'avais déjà dit mais
c'était que quand tu es youtuber et que
tu fais tout chez toi tout le temps bas
psychologiquement c'est assez dur en
fait c'est dur d'être dans la même pièce
tout le temps toute l'année
bon là je dis ça on est à moitié confiné
couvre-feu et donc on s'est un peu
habitué mais à l'époque mois après trois
années ça m'avait vraiment pesé et c'est
pour ça que j'avais besoin d'aller un
endroit de croiser des gens de faire
comme tout le monde d'aller au travail
le matin et ça m'a fait vraiment du bien
évidemment il ya plein de jeux indés il
ya eu the last guardian et puis aussi vu
l'arrivée des vidéos à plusieurs orgue
et ming la première vous avec maxence ou
des fois je la regarde pas ce que c'est
un souvenir c'était c'était n'importe
quoi même sa coupe c'était n'importe
quoi c'est là aussi où il ya eu des
vidéos on débat des objets japonais avec
ma famille karito l'arrivée natsu
l'arrivée natsu c'était qu'on y avait ce
studio tout l' aventure avec alain rey
big flo et oli les premières vidéos
réaction les premiers seraient d'horreur
les premières vidéos anecdotes aussi
bref la plupart des formats que je fais
encore aujourd'hui son nez dans ce décor
là et je pense que c'est cette période
là qu'à marquer un tournant sur la
chaîne youtube et là un jour à l'eau
florent petit frère bien mais une
couleur sur le mur tu fais un truc qui
te fais tu fais mon décor merci ça ou
safari
tadam il était incroyable celui là
c'était plus moi un peu plus adulte un
peu plus beau c'est aussi et - clichy
avec juste des étagères et des mangas
derrière et niveau vidéo bon on a
continué tous ces formats en en a'
masterisé et puis des fois on s'est fait
des petits kif à droite à gauche comme
les hits de l'été des vidéos avec natsu
des activités manuelles tout ça jusqu'à
aujourd'hui jusqu'au 10 ans sur youtube
et c'est parce que au même moment du
coup on change une nouvelle fois de
décor cette fois j'ai opté pour un décor
3d j'ai vu qui en a qui étaient un peu
deg mais en fait dans tous les cas les
décors de youtube earth etc des décors
c'est du fake c'est juste pour qu'il ya
un truc derrière nous quand on tourne je
me suis juste dit que c'était cool de
pousser le truc est de faire un vrai
truc qui n'existe pas dans la vraie vie
mais on dirait qu'ils existent et
surtout c'est plus simple pour moi du
coup de tourner des vidéos je peux le
faire d'où je veux quand je veux et il
me faut juste un fond vert et ça permet
aussi de dissocier les vidéos des
contenus des live parce qu'en fait c'est
la même pièce regarder au pelage brise
la magie magie brive est en fait c'est
la même pièce je mets vidéo ses juges
chez moi là aussi où joue en off cancans
je fais pas de live ou pas de vidéo mais
j'aimais bien l'idée dissocier les deux
et de mettre une ambiance différente
pour les deux les laves c'est pas une
chose que les vidéos quand même excusez
moi je joue mes scénarios décor à
excellent excellent excellent c'est
marrant le temps est tellement passé que
on essayait on est à l'époque où je peux
regarder les vidéos de moi dans lesquels
je regardais des vidéos de moi vieille
genre dans ces vidéos là le mois qui
réagit est aussi vieux pour nous à
l'heure actuelle que le mois dans la
c'est chiant mais après ces dix ans les
gars y'a aussi des soldats qui nous ont
quittés et oui qui ne sont plus dans le
navire qui sont partis vers d'autres
horizons qui n'a plus contenue qui même
plus moi peut-être même mais globalement
dans mon cas et c'est ça qui ouvre c'est
la plupart des gens sont restés en fait
et on continue à regarder les vidéos et
c'est un [ __ ] d'honneur en fait et
croyez moi je me régale jouit de cette
position et ses privilèges à 300% s'est
pas dit avec des fois j'ai pas une belle
phase de déprime ou des moûts d'un peu
de moyens on est des humains peu importe
qui on est ce qu'on fait on a tous des
hauts et des bas mais [ __ ] quel kiff
qu'on est sans même parler de la
stabilité professionnelle que ça
représente je veux dire qu'elle kiffe
d'avoir vu cette communauté youtube
grandir comme ça vieillir mûrir il ya un
truc qui est super émouvant je trouve on
était vraiment tous des ados émerveillés
par les mêmes choses et internet et
youtube en l'occurrence a créé une sorte
de pont entre nous tous et je sais pas
je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose de très
beau là dedans tant qu on est là à
discuter j'aimerais bien vous parlez
aussi de ce que ça a changé
la notoriété pour moi au delà de payer
mes factures plus facilement ça va
changer que ça il ya aussi eu des trucs
qui me sont tombés dessus et que j'avais
pas anticipé parce que bas je pensais
une anticipable déjà il ya un truc j'ai
remarqué récemment et cassé ou c'est que
la chaîne elle est devenue très grand
public aujourd'hui contrairement à
l'époque où c'était un peu plus niche ou
un peu plus axé genre les adolescents et
très jeunes adultes fans de gaming
aujourd'hui on dirait pas mais là parmi
tous ceux qui regardent la vidéo il ya
des enfants des ados des trentenaires et
des parents qu'elle garde avec leurs
enfants et c'est fou les gars je suis
devenu disneyland
je suis devenu le train de la mine
qu'est ce qui se passe je rigole mais je
suis honoré de fou de pouvoir faire
kiffer des gens qui ont un âge c'est
différent et qui du coup ont des goûts
et sont attirés par des choses qui
normalement sont censés être assez
différentes
sauf que du coup les contenus que je
fais bas ils vont probablement plus
plaire aux il ya un jumbo qui veut au
jumbo médium velouté l'appui longtemps
mec t'es là depuis mega man thor fait
remonter la puce décor la regarder comme
il était jeune
oh ouais attention est ce que vous êtes
prêts à faire un comparatif avec l'image
de la chaîne du coup je trouve ça hyper
cool cette position qui réunit autant de
gens différents t'as pas le micro avec
tata que frêche mais aussi je me dis que
j'ai un peu condamnés à faire des déçus
et j'envoie à chaque fois que sur un
truc des déçus et en fait c'est devenu
récurrent est normal mais contrairement
à avant parce que je me pose pas la
question de il faut que ça plaise à tout
le monde donc il faut faire un truc
comme ça non je fais un truc qui me
plaît à moi avant tout est donc
logiquement qui plaît essentiellement
aux gens comme mon âge
alors ça reste une minorité de malades
quand je sors un projet mais il ya
forcément des déçus et au début je vais
pas vous mentir ce même une claque et ça
m'a un peu fait déprimer de voir autant
de gens déçus à chaque fois et m'a fallu
du temps avant de me dire mais en fait
mec c'est normal il ya tellement de gens
différents aujourd'hui qui regardent les
vidéos que forcément certains contenus
plaisent à certaines personnes et
d'autres contenus à d'autres avec tout
ça aussi bas du coup j'ai pu prendre mon
indépendance
et oui vous le savez j'ai quitté webedia
j'ai créé ma propre structure j'ai mes
propres bureaux qui sont qu'à moi et
tout ça ça entraîne le luxe le plus
ultime à savoir le luxe de pouvoir
choisir avec qui tu travailles et donc
de faire kiffer des gens que tu aimes
que tu admires et qui sont talentueux et
c'est robert des humains fort genre
lorraine qui montrent son bureau à
l'envers et un autre luxe et ça c'est un
luxe qui fait culpabiliser pour le coup
c'est fait de se dire que moi
aujourd'hui si j'ai une idée d'un clip
d'un court métrage d'un truc je peux me
débrouiller j'ai ce qu'il faut pour
pouvoir la réaliser cette idée et je
sais que il ya des gens
fort probablement même certains bien
plus fort que moi qui n'ont pas cette
chance
et du coup bas toi quand tu as cette
chance tu te dis [ __ ] faut que j'en
sois digne et ça je pense que c'est un
syndrome que pas mal de gens du web ont
ce truc de [ __ ] on est des gros
chanceux et on a des possibilités assez
illimité alors sachez qu'avant tout moi
je me faire plaisir sur cette chaîne
c'est pour ça je parlais de andre the
giant légendes du catch je le fais je
veux réagir à des trucs sur un sujet qui
me fait marrer je le fais mais aussi je
continuerai toujours des fois de faire
des trucs un peu plus poussées comme
cache cache comme des clips
j'adore faire des clips c'est un travail
qui est très différent et ça me fait
vraiment kiffé je suis hyper content du
dernier clip mario kart c'est pas
forcément les trucs qui font le plus de
vues s'est même les trucs qui font le
moins de vue aurait été sur la chaîne
alors qu'ils demandent beaucoup plus de
travail que une vidéo réaction par
exemple moi je vais pas vous mentir
j'adore ces trucs de réaction de ce raid
horreur d'histoire de fer lhermitte de
mon bureau qui parle de trucs qui réagit
à des trucs et je sais que ça en fait
grincer des dents certains qui se disent
mais [ __ ] il est à son 1000e ce bris
dit vas-y fais autre chose frérot mais
non j'adore en vrai je fais autre chose
sauf que ça représente pas la majorité
de mon contenu problème en tout cas tous
ces formats vont rester sur la chaîne y
en aura peut-être des nouveaux je vais
renforcer un peu les trucs en extérieur
les trucages justement un peu plus
concept mais tout ce que je fais ici
dans mon bureau je continuerai à le
faire parce que c'est ce qui m'anime et
vous le savez ça fait quelques années
maintenant que j'ai dit maintenant
j'espère que ce que je kiffe et [ __ ]
c'est la meilleure décision que j'ai
prise de ma vie autre chose aussi après
ses 10 ans c'est que grâce à vous j'ai
appris à aimer qui suit on a tous des
complexes on a tous des faiblesses on
est tous différent on est tous impactés
par le regard des autres à différentes
échelles pendant longtemps moi je
m'étais mis une carapace où j'étais pas
complètement mois les anciens seront
georges rigoles énormément pour vraiment
un truc nul et je me forçais nature et
de bonne humeur a toujours trouvé cool
le truc que auquel j'ai assisté alors
qu'en fait banon des fois c'est de la
merde et donc j'ai fait switch je me
suis dit mais vas-y maintenant je vais
être moi des fois je vais être un peu
plus râleurs et fois je vais être
fatigué mais c'est pas grave c'est
normal de passer dans plein de détails
mais c'est humain en fait et du coup
depuis bah évidemment les critiques je
me le prends toujours plein tête mais
par contre le positif je me le prends
beaucoup plus à coeur parce que du coup
bas comme un complément et en plus
d'être trop gentil avec moi de malades
bas c'est vraiment moi que vous
complimenter c'est pas un alter ego que
j'ai créés ou un perso c'est vraiment
moi donc ça me fait ça fait mes gars
chaud au coeur en vrai et donc bref ces
dix ans ça m'a permis ça aussi encore
une fois je pense d'atteindre un truc
que j'aurai atteint beaucoup plus tard
dans ma vie à savoir assumer mais goût
assumé qui suit assumer mes défauts
aussi
des fois je suis méga chiant les gars à
ceux qui regardent les live vous savez
des fois je vais toujours de mauvaise
foi veinarde
mais c'est cool d'être soi et enfin
j'aimerais finir en dix ans une fois de
plus merci est d'autant plus merci que
actuellement comme j'ai dit je suis
grand public et c'est pas la mode de
suivre squeeze de suivre le premier
youtuber de france le deuxième en vrai
c'est à dire que ta première et malgré
ça en fait vous restez vous restez là
vous restez à envoyer de l'amour envahi
de la force quand vous envoyez de la
foire sur l'album j'ai été trop touchés
on en a vendu des dizaines de milliers
alors que c'est un premier album sa
première et c'est pour moi c'est ouf
d'être autant soutenu alors qu'à cet
effet là un peu pervers dont je parle et
ça me va droit au coeur
franchement merci pour votre confiance
ccc ouf bref c'est quoi la suite et ben
déjà j'en sais rien mon frère on va
continuer tout ce qui est réaction va
continuer tout ce qui est histoire
on va continuer tout ce qui est aussi
une histoire d'horreur évidemment on va
faire un peu plus de formats avec des
potes avec seb etc
il y aura aussi un peu des nouveaux
formats qui auront lieu en extérieur en
dehors du bureau
bref c'était une petite vidéo blabla
pour les dix ans de la chaîne c'était
une bonne occasion je trouve de revenir
un peu sur tout ça et que je vous parle
un peu ça me fait toujours du bien en
fait jose de moins en moins parler sur
la chaîne youtube parce que je trouve
c'est des vidéos méga chien et du coup
je suis obligé d'aller faire cliquer
avec mouloud achour pourparlers alors
qu'en fait je peux le faire aussi ici
même après 10 ans je me prends encore
trop la tête sur des trucs c'est
terrible bref merci pour ces dix ans on
va repartir sur dix autres années 25 ans
on peut aller jusqu'au 30/5 je pense à
ça se trouve on ira jusqu'au 65 et on
fera des vidéos anecdote ce genre où je
raconte des trucs ont lieu avec mes
petits enfants seraient ouf période
compliquée avec le coville période
d'autant plus compliqué pour les jeunes
et donc vous si j'ai pu un peu vous
changer les idées quand ça allait pas je
suis ravi c'est que j'ai accompli ma
mission et je compte bien la continuer à
très vite suis un peu ému je suis un peu
ému mais je peux le cacher un peu trop
de fierté je vais le cacher a très vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]